>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, DC.
>> Gail Shirazi: Hello, I'm Gail
Shirazi at the Library of Congress,
I'm a librarian the Israel Judaica
section and I'd like to welcome you
to today's program, The 13th
Hour of Reading and Discussion
of Yiddish Poetry of Rivka
Basman Ben-Hayim presented
by a translator, Professor
Zelda Newman.
The program is cosponsored today by
the Hebraic section of the African
and Middle East Division
here at the library
and the Hebrew Language
Table in cooperation
with the Embassy of Israel.
I would like to thank Sharon
Horowitz in the Hebraic section,
Galena Tovarovski [phonetic] of
the IJ section, Delphine Gamberg
in the Embassy of Israel, and we
have the cultural officer sitting
with us today, Molly Tobin,
her third day on the job.
Thank you Aaron Taub, head of
the Israel and Judaica section
who will also be reading.
And a special thank you to our
main speaker Professor Newman.
Professor Newman received her BA in
philosophy from Brooklyn College,
her MA and PhD in linguistics
from the University of Michigan,
her specialty -- well
she's a linguist,
but her specialty is
Yiddish language and culture.
But she's involved in a
variety of other activities.
She's lived in Israel for 30 years
where she helped found Maslan,
the Women's Center for Victims
of Violence of the Negev.
She was elected to the Academy for
awarding theater prizes in Israel
and is a former head of Judaic
studies at Lehman College of SUNY.
And she has an upcoming biography
of the prolific Yiddish
writer Kadya Molodowsky,
she's now retired and
living in Beersheba.
A few announcements before we begin,
please turn off your cell phones.
This event is being
taped for a webcast.
During the Q&A we're going to span
the audience, so if you do not want
to be filmed, please
leave during that time.
And our program announcements for
programs we're doing in the future
for the Hebrew Language Table
and the books will be
available after the program.
So, I'm going to introduce
Professor Newman, thank you.
>> Zelda Kahan Newman: Thank you.
[ Applause ]
I'd also like to thank the
Hebraic section of the African
and Middle East Studies Division,
the Hebrew Language Table
and the Library of Congress.
Apparently, the Embassy of
Israel is connected with this,
so thank you to everybody.
As a lover of Yiddish and a bookworm
I'm delighted to be here presenting
to you a dual language Yiddish
English book, this one over here.
The Yiddish poems of
Rivka Basman Ben-Hayim
and alongside them my
English translations.
Nothing could be more fitting
English is my native language,
Yiddish is my [foreign language],
the language I heard around me.
The Library of Congress is
an extraordinary institution
and Rivka Basman Ben-Hayim is
an extraordinary individual.
All good literature
illuminates the universal
by examining the particular
and poetry is the most
particular of all literary forms.
As I take you through a tour
of the poet's work the universal
elements will leap out at you.
The particular ones are
ones that I will point out
and I'll fill you in on the details.
Rivka Basman was born in
1925 in the town of Vilkomir
and what the Jews called
[inaudible] or Lithuania.
When she looked back
on her childhood there was
one teacher who stood out.
Here is her poem about that teacher
it's called [foreign language],
My Teacher Riva.
This is how it goes, I'm going
to read it first in Yiddish
and then its translation in English.
[ Speaking Foreign Language ]
Okay, here's the English
translation.
My Teacher Riva.
Like sun in a rain caught in
leaves your image shines forever
in me my teacher Riva.
Unique and eternal your vision,
a truly rooted vigil excuse me,
a truly rooted vigil your love
the strongest my teacher Riva.
So, I absorb the sunset which
has lit before me a corner
of memory through dark pains.
With years wait patiently where time
has no dominion over them and there
in a shtetl in Lithuania, at the
first sung alphabet-letters dripped
with honey and tears I swallowed
your smile loomed in sadness.
Hours will probably overlap
the latter reach the former
and meet somewhere together by seas.
And there in a blue remembrance
your name will gleam pristine,
my teacher Riva.
This poem speaks of the first
alphabet letters gripping
with honey.
It was traditional in Eastern
Europe to introduce young children
to the Hebrew letters with
which Yiddish is written
by dipping a letter baked in
honey and then giving the letter
to the child in the
shape of a letter.
Let's say an olive, the
child would say olive
and then swallow the letter.
This accomplished two things, it
made the Hebrew letters literally
and symbolically a part of the child
and it is associated Jewish learning
with a very pleasant experience.
Rivka new loss at a very
young age, her mother died
when she was still a child,
her grandma stepped in.
When the Nazis emptied Rivka's
town of Jews Rivka was 14.
She held onto her brother
Arele and some
of her poems are dedicated
her brother Arele.
But he was torn out of her hands
and she never saw him again.
Rivka spent two years
in the Vilna ghetto
where she met the great
Yiddish poet Abraham Sutzkever.
Ten years older than Rivka
Sutzkever was already a recognized
Yiddish poet.
When Rivka told Sutzkever that she
herself composed poems Sutzkever
said, keep it up that's what
will keep you alive and it did.
When Rivka was sent
to the Kaiserwald Concentration
Camps she continued
to compose poems.
It's been said that at the
Warsaw uprising the cry went
out [foreign language],
Jews don't be despaired.
And in that same spirit of the
Nazis can control our bodies,
but they can't control
our spirit the women
of this concentration camp decided
to entertain the inmates every day.
So at the end of every grueling
workday there were three women
who entertained the
inmates, one sang, one danced
and one composed a poem
and recited it that day.
It was Rivka who composed a
poem and recited it every day.
This is Rivka's description
of that experience.
It's called the Dermonung.
Remembrance first in Yiddish.
[ Speaking Foreign Language ]
Okay, here's the translation
Remembrance.
They remember how I used to
write poems, crying poems,
silence poems on the
red cobblestones.
Remember me at the barbed fence,
my young skin tattooed
from barbed points.
To see a tiny threat of sunset of
my own setting in that last sun.
I sang then and my poem
was itself our sun.
Okay, that's her poem about them.
It's worth pointing out
that nowhere in this poem
or in any poem ever written
by Rivka are the Nazis
or the Germans ever
mentioned outright never.
It's as though the Germans were
not allowed to control the spirits
of the women and they are not
allowed into Rivka's closed world
of Yiddish poetry,
they're closed off.
But that of course, does not
mean that the inmates were able
to forget what had happened.
The trauma was with them for life.
Here is Rivka's honest
description of that
and it's called [foreign language].
[ Speaking Foreign Language ]
And this is the translation
We Are Restless.
We are restless from wandering.
We are restless from
seeking a cave in the night
so a star shouldn't spot us.
We are restless for
longing for those
who never did die and are dead.
We are restless from being unable
to tell ourselves of our unrest.
So Rivka did exactly as Sutzkever
had predicted Rivka found solace
in poetry, in her ability to
find words for complex emotions
and in the satisfaction that
comes with the artistic creation.
Of course, a poet needs inspiration
and the news may be fickle,
it may not come when it's cold.
This is Rivka's poem describing
the gratification that comes
with finding the precise
word [foreign language],
that's the way the French call it.
Okay it's called [foreign language].
Just a minute, I thought
I had it here.
Just a second, [foreign language]
okay, [foreign language].
[ Speaking Foreign Language ]
If you can and you will
it becomes calm and still.
When it becomes so good, so easy
it sings by itself, of itself.
The sounds listen to their own calm.
Rare when there's such
a becalmed calm.
I'd go there more often if
I knew how and to where.
So that's her poem on
poetic inspiration.
Back now to the end of the war.
By the end of the war Rivka's father
was no longer alive, he was murdered
in a camp in Estonia just
before the war ended.
So, at the war's end Rivka
was alone in the world.
She met and married Shmuel
nicknamed Mula Ben-Hayim
after the war in Belgrade.
Mula ran the Belgrade station of
the organization known as Berihah,
the Hebrew word for
flight or escape.
The members of this organization
gathered the stateless Jews then
wandering all over Europe wanted
by no one and sent them illegally
to what was then Palestine.
Here then was a young couple
just starting life together
who took it upon themselves
to dodge the Interpol,
the Interpol was looking for them
and put their lives in danger
to help settle fellow Jews
in the one place in the world
that was happy to have them then.
It's not surprising then that
when Rivka and Mula, her husband,
arrived in Israel in 1947,
they settled in a kibbutz
called Ha-Ma'pil.
Literally Ha-Ma'pil means
one who ascends, who goes up.
This kibbutz took its name from
a passage in the Book of Numbers,
chapter 14, verse 44 and
that's the original story
of Ha-Ma'pil those who ascend.
Those of you who are so inclined
can look it up, those of you are not
so inclined can ask in the
Q&A section there's a story
about why this kibbutz
was called Ha-Ma'pil.
What mattered for Rivka was that
on the kibbutz she could heal.
She watched things grow,
she got a teaching degree
and she taught children
and she watched them grow.
And that for her was therapeutic.
Most important, she had Mula,
the love of her life
and her life partner.
Mula was an artist,
he's no longer alive.
This picture that you see here
is his picture and all the prints
in this book are his prints.
This is a poem addressed
to him essentially to Mula,
it is called [foreign language].
[ Speaking Foreign Language ]
With you I am calm, remember
she spoke about being restless
so with Mula, her husband,
she is calm.
With you I am calm and close and
I need not withhold any words
like leaves in a sun-lit
crown anchored in their earth.
With you I am entirely with
myself rooted to streaming wonder,
which nests in drops of
light even as it goes under.
With you the day is not divided,
no separate now and yesterday,
clothed in endless green and
you're the eternal sentry.
Anyone notice that the
book is dedicated to Mula?
Rivka wanted it that way.
Never one to avoid harsh truths
Rivka had to admit that even
as she healed the pain
did not disappear.
In the following poem, she speaks
of a slow process of healing
and the untouched depths of grief.
And now Aaron will read
the next five poems
for you [foreign language].
>> Aaron Taub: Okay,
can you hear me?
I don't know if you can.
So, I want to thank Zelda for
her beautiful translations.
And I also want to say participating
in this reading is
especially meaningful to me
because I met Rivka Basman Ben-Hayim
in 2009, when I was giving a reading
at [inaudible] in Tel
Aviv and Rivka was there
and was extremely encouraging
and supportive.
And more recently,
for a literary event
of contemporary Yiddish poetry she
translated one of my Yiddish poems
into Hebrew and did a
really beautiful job.
So, I wrote her a little note.
All right, so Di Depts.
[ Speaking Foreign Language ]
You've stitched my ripped
surface, pasted and gathered
until there appeared a tiny
light and I forgot about myself.
I'm just about healed, but the
depths they haven't yet spoken.
>> Zelda Kahan Newman:
Thank you Aaron.
I don't know if we're going to
show this clip, but I should point
out that the second line
of the poem you're going
to hear is [foreign language]
and that is reference
to the biblical verse
[foreign language].
From out of the depths I called
and Rivka's poems are
from out of the depths.
In the pre-World War 2 era
the Jewish world was divided
between the advocates of Yiddish
as the language of the Jews
and of Hebrew as the
language of the Jews.
When the state of Israel was
young Yiddish was denigrated
as the language of the diaspora
which Israelis were
told to get rid of.
In the inclusive way that is typical
of her and Rivka does translate
from Hebrew to Yiddish and back.
Rivka was both Yiddish and Hebrew.
She spoke Hebrew of course, but she
joined a group called Yung Yisroel.
This was a group of writers
that was intent on maintaining
and encouraging artistic
creation in Yiddish
within a Hebrew speaking
environment.
And here is Rivka's poem
called the [foreign language],
the Intimacy Between
Yiddish and Hebrew.
[ Speaking Foreign Language ]
>> Aaron Taub: The Intimacy
of Yiddish and Hebrew.
How to explain intimacy
Perhaps the way Yiddish
breathes into a Hebrew word warms
up the letters, gives
them a softer step.
And then when Yiddish tells Hebrew
about her tears both languages
pray the identical prayer to God.
>> Zelda Kahan Newman: In this poem
that you've just heard the poet not
only tells us about the intimacy
between Yiddish and Hebrew
she actually demonstrates it.
Yiddish often take a Hebrew word
and Yiddishizes [phonetic]
[foreign language]
or in Yiddish [foreign language]
or [foreign language] it.
As you may know, tomato,
tomato Yiddish has dialects,
so it's [foreign language]
in one dialect
and [foreign language] in another.
From the noun [foreign
language] as we say
in modern Hebrew Yiddish creates
the verb [foreign language]
and we say [foreign language]
or [foreign language] depending
on your dialect, they dream.
Now there is a Yiddish noun for
the verb to pray, the verb prayer
and that is [foreign language]
in modern Israeli Hebrew
or [foreign language] in
Yiddish that's how it is,
the Yiddish adopts the word and
Yiddishizes it [foreign language].
But the Yiddish verb
for praying is not
from that noun it is
the verb davening,
that is the standard
Yiddish word for praying.
But in this poem Rivka does not use
the standard verb davening instead
she creates a new Yiddish verb
from the Yiddish [foreign language]
she makes a new verb [inaudible],
it's the verb that she made from
the noun [foreign language] to pray.
So, she takes the verb,
the noun [foreign language]
or [foreign language] and she
makes it into the verb [inaudible].
It's a possible word in Yiddish just
because Yiddish can and does draw
on Hebrew nouns to
make Yiddish verbs.
And this is intimacy in action.
When Rivka was a child she read
and grew to love the poetry
of Kadya Molodowsky
that's as you pointed out,
that's my next project a
biography of Kadya Molodowsky.
Kadya Molodowsky was the
most prolific woman writer
of Yiddish ever.
And right after the Holocaust
Kadya wrote a poem called [foreign
language] translated into
English as Merciful God.
And in that poem, she rallied
against God and she said
to him, choose another people.
Now the way I see it Rivka responded
to Kadya's charge against God
in her poem entitled
[foreign language].
[ Speaking Foreign Language ]
>> Aaron Taub: Whiteness
for Kadya Molodowsky.
If whiteness were to cover
everything I would wait for you.
And in the white world I
would ask about your footfall.
If whiteness were to cover
everything I would recognize your
pace and with each step
I'd ask so where isn't God.
>> Zelda Kahan Newman: Poets do
not speak the language of rhetoric
or philosophy theirs is
a language of sense data.
Remember that Rivka in her
private language the color
of beauty and wonder is blue.
Remember, she spoke
about a blue remembrance
from the teacher of her youth.
But for Kadya white was her
private color for wonder and beauty.
And in this poem Whiteness Rivka
is responding to Kadya's complaint.
She counters that complaint against
God by pointing to the beauty
and wonder of nature, his world and
she says is God not there as well
and she leaves that tantalizing
question up in the air.
From 1963 to 1965, Rivka's husband
Mula was Israel's cultural attache
to what was then the Soviet Union.
There dodging the ever-present
KGB Rivka met clandestinely
with beleaguered Yiddish writers.
And there again, her
courage came to the fore.
In their last years together Rivka
and Mula lived in the Artists Colony
in [inaudible] and that is when
he painted this beautiful picture
that you see over here of
[inaudible] called Safed.
I'd like to share with you two
more poems, the first is a poem
on friendship called [foreign
language], Younger Than time.
[ Speaking Foreign Language ]
>> Aaron Taub: Younger Than Time.
There is an old friendship young I
appearance which comes and speaks
of cherry blossoms, preserves the
sap which a honeybee has long lost.
There is an old friendship younger
than time, it comes and inquires
about each separately, a silence
that's concealed rejuvenates
the mind.
There is an old friendship
younger than time.
>> Zelda Kahan Newman: I
want to explain to all of you
that [foreign language]
literally means years
and I translate it as time.
If you knew Rivka's
[inaudible] you would know
that she often uses [foreign
language] to mean time.
And I discussed this with her
and she said it's okay,
it's okay time is good.
So, it's not by accident I do know
what [foreign language] means,
it means years, but that's
how she means it here.
I owe my editor, Judith P.
Kerman an insight into this poem.
There's a line I the poem that
Aaron just read for you which goes
like this, it comes and speaks about
each separately, so Judith said
to me each what, each
person, each event, each what,
you're leaving her hanging.
And the answer of course,
is that with genuine
friendship you need not spell out
or give voice to everything.
If you and your friend are on
the same wavelength you can
and do leave things unsaid and still
there's complete understanding.
So that is why Rivka does
not say about each what,
about each you know the rest,
your friend knows the rest.
The final poem that I want
to share with you happens
to be the last one
in this collection.
I think it is a profound
insight on the magic
of music and its hold over us.
It is entitled [foreign language].
[ Speaking Foreign Language ]
>> Aaron Taub: The Song
with the Old-Time Refrain.
The song with the old-time refrain
returns and returns once again.
Exact words eluded, but it longs for
the tear in them, which has no fear
of time and still looks for
the rider who rides bedecked
in golden spurs, who comes
and says and deceives.
And then it remembers the tear
and seeks a sword in the words
which are drenched
with the sweet lament.
And after that the old refrain.
>> Zelda Kahan Newman: So, I'm going
to give you the way I
understand this poem.
A musical refrain this poem tells
us is hard to shake because it comes
with memory and anticipation
and hopes.
And even after the sought after
hope are dashed the memory
of them remains and we return to
the music and memories associated
with it because the sounds are
drenched with a sweet lament.
Follow with me the
music of this poem,
the song with the old-time refrain
returns and returns once again.
So here you have word magic
celebrating sound magic.
Now you know why I wanted
to put out this book.
Rivka Basman is an unsung
hero of the Jewish people
and for poems are a gift to
poetry lovers everywhere.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Gail Shirazi: Show the clip
of Rivka reading one of her poem
and then we'll have a chance
for questions and answers.
[ Speaking Foreign Language ]
Anybody have a question?
Haim [phonetic].
[ Inaudible Comment ]
>> Gail Shirazi: We have
to repeat the question.
>> Zelda Kahan Newman: Okay, the
question is how long it takes.
Each poem is different and you
know it's like what Rivka says,
[foreign language], you
can do it and you want it
and sometimes it comes
and sometimes it doesn't.
But there have been times when.
[ Inaudible Comment ]
It would be nice if you get it.
There have been times when
I spend an awful lot of time
on a translation and
the next time I look
at it I erase the whole business.
Every now and then things work
out right, but you've got to get,
you think of the sense, you think
of the rhyme, you think of the meter
and rarely do you get all three.
So, I know one line all in
all in this entire collection,
which I feel pretty comfortable
with and that's [foreign language]
and which I translated as,
a stillness that's concealed
rejuvenates the mind,
which is as close as I could get.
And that requires two things
[foreign language] is a word
that does not exist in Yiddish it's
a neologism the word is [foreign
language] which means spring.
And Rivka makes up the word [foreign
language] to you it would say
in spring, but that's
not a word in English.
So I decided on rejuvenates
because it fit the rhythm
ba-da-ba-da rejuvenates the mind.
And [foreign language] is not
mind [foreign language] is memory,
but I translated it as mind
because it's a half rhyme with time
and because without your
memories have you got a mind.
So, it was two translations
of a sense [foreign language]
with a rhythm that works,
but you know that's so rate
that you get a rhythm and
a half rhyme and the sense,
it's almost asking
for the impossible.
But you try for the impossible,
if you don't try you'll
never get there.
Any other questions?
>> I have a question.
How did she save her
poem, how did she?
>> Zelda Kahan Newman: Oh, thank
you, thank you for saying that.
>> Gail Shirazi: Repeat
the question.
>> Zelda Kahan Newman: So, the
question is how she saves her poems.
When the Nazi camp was liquidated,
the Nazis liquidated the camps they
stripped the prisoners completely
nude and they weren't allowed
to take anything with them.
So, at the camp Rivka wrote her
poems in micrography and rolled
onto her tongue and she
escaped with those poems.
But she says about those
particular poems [foreign language],
they were not sublimated enough.
She feels that they
needed sublimation,
she feels they were
screamed from the heart
and she hasn't published those.
But she says when she meets
her maker she will put them
in [foreign language].
But she feels it didn't go through
enough sifting, it was too much
of a scream and she doesn't
think they're good enough.
But she says they remember
the people they were
with in the camps remembers them
and certainly knows what they are
and she's planning to leave
them with [foreign language]
as a memory, as a toke of what was.
Yes.
>> Can you talk about her life in
[inaudible] before the Holocaust
and what was her background.
>> Zelda Kahan Newman: Background
in [inaudible], so Rivka told me
that in [inaudible] Lithuania
as the Jews called it then was
in northeast Poland at the time.
There were different
shtetl and in her shtetl,
she says was the Yiddish
speaking shtetl so she went
to a Yiddish speaking school.
But Mula Shmuel, her husband,
went to a Hebrew speaking school.
So, each shtetl has
its preferred language.
So, she went to a Hebrew
speaking school and began
to [inaudible] and never finished.
And she got her degree later on
when she was in Israel she went
to get a teaching degree.
But she got to the first year of
the [inaudible] and then it ended,
but it was all in Yiddish
which is how she first knew
about Kadya Molodowsky.
Kadya Molodowsky is known in
Israel for her children's poems.
She's known in this country for
her adult poems and her novellas,
and her short stories
and everything else.
>> Did she come from a
religious background?
>> Zelda Kahan Newman: No, no she
said it was a secular background
and [inaudible], it was not
religious background at all.
She's a very inclusive sort of
person, she knows that I'm religious
and she always calls me before
Shabbos, never afterwards
and she'll ask me what
time candle lighting is
so that we can have a
conversation beforehand.
You had a question?
[ Inaudible Comment ]
She and I speak Yiddish together,
but she does often switch.
In fact, there's a wonderful
story, we went to [inaudible]
which is the Yiddish writers house.
And someone said, don't speak Hebrew
speak Yiddish [foreign language]
and she said [inaudible]
always a Jewish language.
So, she had nothing against Hebrew,
but of course, Yiddish as she says
in one of these poems, Yiddish words
live for her instead of people.
They are what was left of
her world which is gone
and the Yiddish word are
instead of that world.
So, for her Yiddish is crucial,
but [inaudible] superior.
Unlike most of the other
Yiddish writers [inaudible]
who may have not had such
a good grasp of Hebrew,
her grasp of Hebrew is terrific.
But the poem that you didn't see was
in [foreign language], in silence
or stillness I speak
Yiddish [foreign language],
but by day [foreign language],
by day it's easier for
me to speak Hebrew.
But at night when there's
no one around in her dreams
and her nightmares she speaks
Hebrew [foreign language]
when she's calling out.
Yes, any other questions?
>> Can you say something
about the state
of the Yiddish publishing today.
We all know it's not what it
was, but there are the centers
and our people publishing
and is there another
generation picking up on it?
>> Zelda Kahan Newman:
Okay, I'm glad you asked.
Yes, what's the state of Yiddish
today, Yiddish publishing today.
In Israel, I think there's
a good deal of hope.
There are people still writing
Yiddish [inaudible] who teaches
at the University of
Indiana is a wonderful poet,
but he calls himself Boris Karloff.
So, his poetic name is Boris Karloff
and he used to put out books,
but now he does everything
on the internet.
And he's a young man,
relatively young compared
to my advanced old age.
And then [inaudible] in Israel and
he has won an award for his poetry.
So, it's still going on,
but is there an audience
for Yiddish poetry.
So, here we have to talk
about parallel worlds.
There's a world of Yiddish speakers
growing by leaps and bounds,
that's the world of [inaudible].
The [inaudible] are very careful
and all the other [inaudible]
groups they speak Yiddish
from the minute they open
their eyes to the end
of the day among themselves, but
they don't read Yiddish poetry.
Now let's go to a parallel
world, there's a parallel world
of Yiddish poets, but
they don't think Yiddish
from the moment they open their
eyes to the end of the day.
So, I do my best to go
from world to world.
I'm interested in the living Yiddish
of [inaudible] and there's research
on that, I did a bit and
there's somebody else continuing
at the [inaudible]
University of New York.
It's a growing, wonderful, living
language, it's not dying whatsoever,
but they don't read
[foreign language].
Now will they ever produce their
own literary [inaudible], who knows.
As it looks now the two
parallel lines they don't meet,
there's the world of [inaudible]
and they write, but not the sort
of Yiddish poetry like Rivka does.
And there's the world of Yiddish
poets, but they're not [inaudible]
and I try to be a bridge, but they
don't usually talk to each other,
I wish they did, but they don't.
>> Gail Shirazi: Any
other questions?
>> I have one last one,
can you please talk
about the name of the [inaudible].
>> Zelda Kahan Newman: Oh
okay, so [foreign language].
There's a story it the Book
of Numbers about the children
of Israel they have just
sinned with a sin of the spies
and Moses tells them they
will not enter the land
of Israel except for
two who didn't sin.
They cannot, they will not, they
have to wander in the desert.
And after he tells them
this defiantly they decide
to it says [foreign language],
they ascended the top of the summit
of the hill and they try to
enter and they were routed.
And Moses said if you
try you'll be defeated,
they tried they were
defeated, they didn't manage.
So, after the war the
Zionists looked around.
There's a traditional
understanding in in Jewish thought
that there will come a day
when there will be peace
in the whole world, justice will
reign and God will gather the,
do a gathering of all Jews
to the land of Israel.
Well the Zionists looked around
after the Holocaust and guess what,
there was no peace all over the
world, justice did not reign,
and there didn't seem to be any
way God was taking the children
of Israel to the land of Israel.
And they said we're defiant
we're going to do it.
There was a song [foreign language],
let us [inaudible] and we'll manage,
we'll do it, we won't be
routed, we'll succeed,
well enter the land of Israel.
They call themselves
[foreign language] based
on the defiant assent, but they
said we won't, we won't lose,
we'll get it, we'll get
into the land of Israel.
And this kibbutz was
called Ha-Ma'pil.
We will get into the land
of Israel, we will do it.
If we wait too long there'll be
no Jewish people to bring there.
So, these were the early
Zionists and remember she
and her husband were
part of this group
who illegally brought
Jews to Palestine.
So, they went to this kibbutz
which was part of Ha-Ma'pil those
who believe that there's a
chance for the children of Israel
to get together on the road.
Yeah.
>> Can you talk about
your translation process,
I mean do you work with her, do
you show them to her [inaudible]?
>> Gail Shirazi: Repeat
the question.
>> Zelda Kahan Newman: Okay Adam's
question is do I work with Rivka.
So, at the very beginning I showed
her what we [foreign language],
a pile of poems.
And I was really concerned
because she did not think anybody
had done a good job so far.
And she looked at poem after poem
and she had not encouraged me
at all, we had never known each
other and she said it's a waste
of your time and mine, no
one's ever done an okay job.
And after she looked at I don't
know the 20th translation she looked
at me and she said,
[foreign language] in Hebrew.
So, we became friends and she
thought I did an okay job.
But when I lived when I taught
at the [inaudible] University
of New York she would
send me poems in the mail
and then I'd write her back
or I'd see her when I came
to Israel and we'd discuss it.
And every now and then there's
a word that can be either a noun
or a verb and I'll say, you
know, which one is best.
And we sit together often just
by ourselves in [inaudible]
and I show her my translations
and we talk, we shoot the breeze.
She tells me the background
of her poems sometimes,
it's wonderful hours I
have memories of just her
and me alone in this big room.
Not always has she seen every
translation, but she trusts me
and I hope I don't betray her trust.
On the whole she knows most of these
and I myself am not happy, you know,
with some things I'll
change it next time.
There's no perfection
in this business.
>> Has anybody done a
biography of her and if not,
have you thought maybe that
would be one of your projects?
>> Zelda Kahan Newman: Well right
now I want to finish the one
on Kadya Molodowsky who had
some things about her life
that were pretty much not known.
Rivka is very not, she's very
careful about people not talking
about her, she's a very
nonassertive person, very private.
And when one person wanted to do a
movie about her she was hesitant.
If there's something she
doesn't want to talk about,
doesn't talk about the details
of what happened in the camps,
she does not want to and you have
to respect her privacy on that.
With me she's told me
parts about her life,
but I think she wants her poetry to
speak for her that's my impression.
That she doesn't especially want
a biography she wants her poems
to speak for her.
I could be wrong, but
that's my impression.
I would her ask about it, but right
now poetry she wants and she put
out a book in 2016, we're in 2016.
She's 90 years old and she
published a book this year.
Yeah.
>> So two more questions,
have her poems been translated
to other languages?
And then also given that
she has so many books
out how are you able to [inaudible]?
>> Zelda Kahan Newman: Okay,
so the first question is has she
been published in other languages?
She has indeed in many,
I don't know how many,
but I know her Hebrew
translator is named [inaudible]
who is a dear friend
of hers and I would
like to think he is
a friend of mine.
He teaches [inaudible].
He's her Hebrew translator, but
she's been translated into German
and into Swedish and I
think Korean and French.
If you look at the back of the
book there's a woman named Sabine
who has done her translations into
French, there's a website for it
and you can see it online.
I don't know how many,
but quite a number.
Your second question was?
>> How are you able to [inaudible]?
>> Zelda Kahan Newman: Yes, and each
time i think oh I didn't include
that one oh, what a pity.
I can't even decide really,
there's some that are favorites.
The poem about friendship
is one of my favorites.
There are some that I really love,
the last poem of the
sleep [foreign language].
Some I love for their rhythm,
some for their sense,
they're all beautiful.
It's hard, it's almost like deciding
between your children
it's very difficult.
I don't know how I decided,
it was what I thought would
give enough of a range.
She has one poem called [foreign
language] which is what we call
in Yiddish [foreign language].
It doesn't sound like she's this
woman of sweetness and light,
but she knows how to answer I
don't know what to say with a barb,
but she has all kinds of,
she's an honest person.
And when she feels it's
necessary to let someone know,
someone who she says at their
heart lies a stone not exactly a
compliment, so it's hard.
I tried to do one like
that so that you know
that it isn't all wonderful.
And she's a woman whose known pain.
I didn't include the one poem she
considers her political poem, one.
I once said to Rivka,
you know, you don't write
about politics, she
said oh I did once.
I said what was that, it's the poem
about we should never
give out a death sentence.
That's the poem we should
never have a death sentence.
And you might think it's because
we're all human, we're all created
in God's image, no such thing.
We should never punish anyone,
give them a punishment of death
because life itself is painful,
let them live, let them suffer.
So, you never know what
she's going to say.
That's what she considers
her one political poem.
Yeah, you had a question.
>> Yeah.
>> Zelda Kahan Newman: Uh-huh.
[ Inaudible Comment ]
Yeah okay, so in the 1960's, early
1960's, she went to [inaudible]
and she went through Poland on
their way home from the Soviet Union
and she has poems there and
they are extremely difficult,
one at [inaudible] gravesite.
It's so hard to translate, I tried.
But you have a word like [foreign
language] you can't translate
that with one word.
You know they talk about [foreign
language], it requires paragraphs.
So, I couldn't include that because
it's just not easily translated.
Those were the ones which
were the references.
She has a poem in this book
which I think the reprises Archibald
McLeish, a poem should be palpable
and mute as a globed fruit
and she has one here,
which is a poem is a plum and
its structure is like that
and its sense is like that.
So, she's pretty smart and
she reads an awful lot,
but she really mentions
them by name.
And she has a few references
to Sutzkever, so yeah.
But you've got to know enough to
know just as you've got to know
that when she says
[foreign language],
it's a reference to
[foreign language].
You know she says a
lot with very little,
so the more you know
the more you understand.
>> I came late I'm afraid apologies
so perhaps you mentioned this.
Was she published by
Sutzkever [inaudible]?
>> Zelda Kahan Newman: Absolutely,
that's how I got to know about her.
I had a subscription to
the Golden [inaudible]
and every time I saw a
poem of hers it moved me.
So, I would sit when the kids
were quiet or I had some free time
and I'd do a translation
and then after years
of accumulating translations I
-- actually I call the kibbutz.
I went to the library, those days
libraries are not what they are now
and I looked it up and it said she
lived in kibbutz I the library.
Those days libraries is not what
they are now and he looked it up
and it said she lived
in kibbutz Ha-Ma'pil.
When I called kibbutz Ha-Ma'pil
they said, oh Rivka left years ago,
but if it's Tuesday she's at the
dentist and if it's Wednesday she's
in [inaudible] and they were right.
So, I knew her from her work
in the Golden [inaudible],
not from her collections
I didn't know those.
And then of course,
later I got copies.
Yeah.
>> Did you consider having
footnotes for some of the harder?
>> Zelda Kahan Newman: The only,
there is one footnote in here.
Yeah, there's one here which
is perhaps I should have
on the [foreign language].
There's one footnote here and that's
for the word [foreign language]
because the editor said well who
knows what [foreign language] is.
Okay, so we had a little footnote
about [foreign language], but no,
I didn't and perhaps
that's a mistake.
I don't know.
>> Gail Shirazi: Any
other questions?
Well thank you all
for coming and I want
to thank Rivka, it was a wonderful.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at LOC.gov.